I think it should be Stephen Frye.
Once said: "A real thing is a lie after being badly expressed." This is the theory.
The language you speak determines how you think and...
Yes, it will affect how you look at everything. The key to the problem is: no expression, no expression, no content
There is no form, an idea that feels profound to you, does not exist.
Until you can write it down, or in some cases
Put it in the movie. Watching Dennis Villeneuve’s Advent is to watch the film director’s mastery of the language, he presets
The point is just to show: He has a strong film
ability. I feel as a fan, I can hardly tell you how comfortable this is.
When you are in a world built by people who know how to create movies
Many of the films are now scattered so much that the audience has to pay
More energy to compensate for the distraction. In this regard, I think that Advent has seen so much for us.
The rotten film made a perfect response. Almost all other films made mistakes, "Advent" is doing the right thing, this action is effective and influential.
And it looks at focusing on the things that affect and impact us.
"Language" But I think "Advent" also focuses on the language of the film, just like writing, verbal or alien
Languages, such as the beginning of several scenes, are a bit like
Amplification experiment of the Kulesov effect - the phenomenon that the audience gets meaning from two consecutive shots, Hitchcock is famous
Turning a gentle gentleman into a pervert with a reverse lens
Villeneuve uses the full scene in Advent
Do the same thing. The first scene is a montage depicting Amy Adams
The birth and death of her daughter, the second scene is that Adams came to her school on the day of the aliens.
Because we saw the tragedy in the first scene, and we think that the timeline of the movie is linear
So we interpret Adams’s indifference here as
Frustrated, her boring appearance is expressing her deep sadness and heartache.
It wasn’t until we watched the film that we knew that the opening montage of the movie happened after the film event.
Adams, who we understand in the second act, is just a blank canvas that is given meaning by us.
"Montage means by moving the combined movie clips quickly in front of your eyes.
To create an idea." The difference between Villeneuve and other directors is that he can
Inspire with film, then blend these ideas on another level, collide and fuse them to create higher
significance.
So, what is the significance of Villeneuve's experiment using the Kurishov effect? Maybe it means the future
Influence the past?
After you read this movie, the conclusion is quite
Reasonable, in fact, the key to reaching the climax of this film is when Adams learned
Aliens are high-dimensional lives, they can see all the time at the same time,
She uses this ability to explore the future and influence her. "I called you, are you?"
"Yes, you played." But you can also read another meaning from the same experience, that is, communication.
limited by
Perspective. From our point of view, at the beginning of the movie, everything tells us that Adams is sad, until later
We only know that it is not true. This is another theme of Advent in the exploration of the entire film -
The limitations of human communication have been strengthened and expanded, and we rely on it.
The physiological limitations of our own sensory feedback, our culture and our own personality imposed on us
limitation. "Believe me, you can
Understanding communication
And in the end, it’s still single. When talking to aliens, communication is actually imagined as a screen, a vague intention
Intermediary. Today, the screen can connect with us, we can also divide us, and the same is true for communication. Communication is a kind
The link between the two parties,
But it is usually a connection that speeds up separation. "Language is the foundation of civilization and the glue that brings people together.
It was also the first weapon to be revealed in a conflict. "We are falling asleep on the wheel, you know what I am talking about."
I know that you know. The key here is not that the two interpretations are
Effective, but both interpretations echoed in other parts of the film, and the topics that were introduced were not
waste. The language of the aliens is round,
This movie is also. The difficulty of cooperation between small groups in the Montana camp reflects the cooperation between countries.
difficult. Louise's understanding of her movement in time is nonlinear in the audience's awareness of the described event.
At the same time. "Non-zero and game?"
Each theme is gradually spread through other moments, characters and other themes.
The theme until it starts to feel like something solid, you start thinking about the relationship between language and time
What is it.
Maybe because the mind is not a thing, but a process, the language takes place in time, just like a movie is
An exchange of time occurs. [Russian]
No other art form can be fixed at a fixed time like a movie.
However, what is a movie? It is a mosaic made with time.
Therefore, "Advent" seems to be about the meaning of the film.
possibility. What is it? Where does it come from? I think Villeneuve imagines it as an alien spaceship:
Mysterious, vague, a kind of expression that is not like written or spoken language, so it is difficult to decipher.
Some boring techniques, characters, and stories are always in the movies.
Always on the background, from different angles, can't avoid
"Advent" is not just a denial of bad film, but an example
I think this is also an exploration of "what makes the film great".
It explores from a unique perspective, a movie can be a gift to fans, just like the same language
Can be a gift from an alien, this perspective allows us to see what kind of
A new world.
Hello everyone, thank you for watching. Happy Wednesday, Happy Valentine's Day, my girlfriend is sitting there. Even now is daytime
She always stayed when I was recording, so I love you baby. anyway. Thank you for sponsoring squarespace
This video.
If you don't know squarespace has been a beautiful winning designer template for your corporate website
So if you are a musician or a restaurant, or something,
Squarespace is an all-in-one tool for designing websites
Changing the domain name is very easy, you don't have to know programming or anything.
If you use a coupon code
You can get a 10% discount on "Nerdwriter" if you are buying for the first time. This is really cool! anyway
Thank you for watching, I hope I can continue to see you next Wednesday.
love you, baby.